blank le dimanche il faut rire un blanc
dimanche
comment faire une blonde le dimanche où
et comment on va contre le blague le
vendredi c'est moi c'est un des rares à
bouder il est sur le dossier
je trouve qu était la plus baroque ce
soir c'est un arabe en france américain
qui rencontre un génie et les trois sont
un peu en galère depuis un moment il
rencontre un génie de monde au génie
dis-moi génie à quel moment je vais m'en
sortir à quel moment je vais être
heureux à quel moment je vais jouer
viger croquer la vie à pleines dents
le génie regarde le français divers
voire très divers voire il dit toi tu va
galérer je pense deux mois et après tu
vas trouver le bonheur
mais on s'est dit ah merci merci
beaucoup et tout acquis à l'américain
vient voir ta vie avoir regardé
l'américain comme celle du toit je pense
tu va galérer trois mois et après tu as
trouvé le bonheur
il dira merci génie merci merci merci il
dit à l'arabe
viens voir venir voir toi il dit ouah je
pense tu va galérer quatre mois et
l'arabie où et après il dit après tu vas
tu habitués
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bravo très belle rentrée 50 pas vous
lasser tant qu'on dit arabes turcomans
accusent le coup la voiture et il va à
un peu le genre ouais il arriva pour
trois mois attendez-vous je m'excuse de
vous interrompre votre si ça vous plaît
c'est un allemand vous avez les feuilles
ou par tekori et qui du coup remet ça je
m'excuse ce que vous avez un travail
pour moi avait coûté vous vous avez un
cul bordé de nouilles
il vient de me tomber une place de sous
directeur général d'une banque à paris
je ne peux pas vous dire la mode parce
que ne peux pas vous dire alors vous
avez pour commencer seize mille euros
par mois une voiture de fonction et un
appartement de fonction vous vous foutez
de ma gueule mais c'est vous qui avez
commencé
[Applaudissements]